if you look up how to do a spiral pass
on the internet which is something I had
to do for this video because I really
suck at throwing footballs the main
thing you'll see is that you need to
position your fingers in a way that'll
make the ball spin as it flies through
the air
I was breaking my arm trying to do this
so I could see a physics problem up
close and the problem is right here when
you throw a good spiral pass the ball
starts pointed up tips over midair and
ends pointed down
we're used to seeing a football do this
but according to physics that's highly
unusual when we throw objects they are
usually going to either retain the same
angle as when they originally thrown
like this loaf of bread or flip over
themselves several times until they land
like this box of Girl Scout cookies so
what is it about a football that makes
it want to tip over I first got
interested in this problem and I'm
guessing 2 000 we published the paper in
2020 so it really was 20 years my name
is Timothy gay I'm an atomic physicist
by day and my secret identity is
football physicist at night
the best way to understand why the ball
turns over is to make an analogy with a
spinning top spinning tops are like
catnip for a physicist on its own a top
falls over give a top a spin and it
stands up it balances itself around a
line a center point that physicists call
the reference axis this axis is
determined by the main force acting on
the object which in this case is gravity
gravity is pulling straight down and the
top is fighting this by spinning around
and wobbling around this vertical line
this reference axis a football is a top
you can spin it in the exact same way
and this is in part because of its shape
both the football and a top are
cylindrically symmetrical as
cylindrically symmetric object is one
which if I rotate you can't tell that
I've that I'm turning it objects which
have this symmetry have a big impact on
how the object behaves when I apply
forces to it so when you spin them
they both wobble around a reference axis
spinning makes all the difference but
once he's been a football in the air its
reference axis gets a little more
complicated
when you throw a nice spiral pass
gravity is only acting as a secondary
force on the ball gravity is trying to
pull the ball down usually making its
path to the ground look like this but
the main force acting against the ball
is the air molecules that are pushing
against it as it flies through the air
ball pushes against the air and the air
pushes back against it but because
gravity makes the ball's trajectory a
parabola the air pushing against the
ball changes directions as it flies when
the ball is moving up the molecules are
acting as downward pressure when it's
coming down the molecules are pushing up
and just like the spinning top pointing
against the downward force of gravity to
stay vertical the spinning football
wants to push against the main force
acting against it the air molecules like
the top on the table the ball is going
to want to wobble around its Center Line
its reference axis and in this case that
ends up being the ball's trajectory its
path through the air what the football
wants to do is exactly what the top
wants to do on the table it wants to
Circle its axis wants to circle around
that Force Direction in the case of the
top the force of gravity never changes
it's always vertical whereas for the
football the axis of the force is
changing you can see all these forces at
play in this slow-mo 3D Recreation the
ball takes off pointing towards the air
pushing against it and wobbling around
its reference axis it follows the
trajectory gravity laid out for it
eventually reaching a point where it
starts coming back down at which point
the air forces are pushing up against it
and the ball points against them but in
regular motion it just looks like the
ball is tipping over
[Music]
it would follow similar trajectory but
it wouldn't tip over and if you tried to
throw a spiral loaf of bread or some
other object it wouldn't tip over either
it only works on objects that are
cylindrically symmetrical like a
football or a rugby ball
a very smart person once said to me
everything is simple once explained it's
a hard problem because first of all
there are a lot of potential
explanations which seem enticing at the
beginning but turn out to be wrong
unfortunately you can't really solve the
problem without using some relatively
sophisticated mathematics but the basic
ideas are simple enough for anybody
that's that's interested in is paying
attention to understand
foreign
[Music]